der aufrechte gang das den auf zuweilen
das ist wohl eine der rätselhaftesten
schritte der menschlichen evolution
schließlich bewegen sich vierbeiner doch
eigentlich sicherer und schneller voran
ein us forschungsteam stellt jetzt eine
erstaunliche these auf dem nach seinem
supernovaexplosion unsere urahnen von
den bäumen geholt haben homo habilis
wurde von millionen von jahren also
durch kosmische ereignisse dazu
gezwungen den aufrechten gang zu
erlernen sie zum seitenwechsel gibt's
täglich faszinierend des seins videos
abonniert den kann da nur dann verpasst
er nicht herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
ein spezielles eisen isotop in den böden
der weltmeere brachte das us
forschungsteam auf die spur konkret geht
es um das eisen isotope 60 das sich rund
um die erde in einer entsprechenden
tiefe in den weltmeeren befindet essent
steht in den sternen wenn sie sich ihrem
ende näher dieser fund lässt sich laut
der fachleute nur damit erklären dass es
zwischen dem piloten und der eiszeit
mehrere supernova explosionen gegeben
haben muss das zeitintervall der
erdgeschichte namens piloten endete vor
etwa 2,6 millionen jahren und das
sogenannte pleistozän also die eiszeit
schloss sich an
in diesem zeitraum sind der aktuellen
studie zufolge also mehrere sterne
indirekter kosmischen nachbarschaft der
erde explodiert die experten und
expertinnen gehen von einer entfernung
von nur rund 160 bis 320 lichtjahren aus
die supernova explosion führten zu
intensiver strahlung die bis auf die
erde gelangen konnte den berechnungen
der us fachleute zufolge hat sich
dadurch die erdatmosphäre aufgewärmt
dazu edwin lenhard der an der studie
beteiligt waren es stellte sich heraus
dass sich die menge der elektrischen
ladungen in der unteren atmosphäre durch
die supernova explosionen um den faktor
50 erhöht haben muss
im klartext bedeutet das dass sich die
untere atmosphäre durch elektronen und
ionen aufgeladen hat und es somit
deutlich mehr blitzen aus wolken zum
erdboden kam denn durch die gute
leitfähigkeit der atmosphäre konnten
elektrisch aufgeladene wolken
höchstwahrscheinlich einen leitenden
kanal
bis zum erdboden finden die blitze
wiederum führten laut der studie zu
enormen waldbränden auf der gesamten
erde wälder wurden großflächig
vernichtet und damit auch der lebensraum
unserer vorfahren die hominiden waren
also gezwungen sich eine neue heimat zu
suchen und siedelten von den wäldern um
in die savanne die fortbewegung in
diesem neuen lebensraum gelang aber mit
einem aufrechten gang deutlich besser
anders als auf den bäumen das gehen auf
zwei beiden vereinten direkt zwei
vorteile zum einen ermöglichte es ihnen
weit in die ferne zuschauen und
angreifer frühzeitig zu merken zum
anderen waren sie somit auch deutlich
als menschen schneller unterwegs auch
über längere strecken hinweg der
evolutionäre druck könnte die hominiden
so also dazu gezwungen haben mehr zeit
auf zwei beinen zu verbringen eine
wirklich steile these doch das
forschungsziel wir noch mehr beweise
dafür gefunden haben
auch geologische analysen von
erdschichten die sich in dem zeitraum
der vermuteten supernova-explosionen
gebildet haben sollen die neue erklärung
zum aufrechten gang untermauern denn
dort sind starke ablagerungen von
kohlenstoff zu finden übrig geblieben
von den wäldern die damals durch die
zahlreichen blitzen wohl großflächig
abgebrannt waren dazu elliott es gibt
keine gute andere erklärung dafür dass
wir diese kohlenstoff abladungen
weltweit nachweisen konnten auch die
entwicklung des nordöstlichen afrikas
dass sich damals aus einem waldgebiet zu
einer savanne entwickelt hatte spricht
für diese these denn schließlich konnten
dort im sogenannten great rift valley
zahlreiche hominiden fossilien
aufgespürt werden und so zieht sein
fazit wir gehen davon aus dass es bei
den hominiden bereits vor den supernova
ereignissen eine gewisse tendenz zum
gehen auf zwei beinen gab aber sie waren
doch in erster linie an das klettern in
bäumen adaptiert andere experten und
expertinnen gehen dagegen davon aus dass
viele verschiedene faktoren im
zusammenspiel dazu führten dass unsere
uhr an den aufrechten gang erlernten
dieser prozess hat demnach schon einige
millionen jahre vor den besagten
sternexplosionen begonnen die aktuelle
studie wird beispielsweise von den us
anthropologen william harth kids miss
kritisiert er ist davon überzeugt dass
unsere urahnen schon lange vor dem
höhepunkt der supernova ist
nun aufrecht gehen konnten wann sehen
wir eine supernova mit bloßem auge am
himmel anklicken anschauen und auf jeden
fall neugierig schon abonnieren bis dann
bleibt dran